we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p here's a
question about the 2020 Democratic
primary yeah hey David I want to get
your take on a a Sanders warren ticket
for 2020 maybe it's too early to say
anything like that but I think they have
a good chance of taking down Trump you
know if they joined forces and we kind
of hit them with everything we got yeah
I just want to get you think on that
David and enjoy your show so listen I do
think it's a little early to talk about
that I personally I would love to in
November of 2020 go and vote for Warren
Sanders or Sanders Warren personally I
think that that would be great I am sort
of skeptical of this idea that Democrats
always employ where they pick a vice
presidential running mate
on the basis of we want someone from the
south or the Midwest who appeal to
evangelicals or whatever I think that
that strategy is out and I think we just
need the best people on progressive
policy so I don't know the answer we've
talked before about when is the right
time to start having that conversation I
don't know that it's now but I do think
it's pretty soon and the idea being we
need to start thinking more in total
about what this ticket is going to look
like and how it's going to be able to
fight and run against Trump pence but on
a personal level I would love to vote
for Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
on a ticket no matter who is at the top
of that ticket make sure you are a
member or patron so that you can get
access to the daily bonus show sign up
at join pakman.com or patreon.com slash
david pakman show I'll see you then
otherwise see you tomorrow